[Music]
oh gee with the fortitude to stick
through it betrayal cuts deep losing
hurts especially when you lose on the
biggest stage your game has to offer
when you lose in front of everyone when
you lose to the underdogs but there's
something worse than losing there's
nothing more painful than being betrayed
seeing someone you considered a friend
turn against you turn against the
philosophy you want share turn against
the band of brothers you put together to
win with and there's nothing better than
getting revenge
[Applause]
Oh
can you believe it Oh G was founded on a
simple principle Johan no tell Sunstein
and tall fly Isaac were tired of being
tossed from team to team without really
getting a chance to develop they
believed that if a team stuck together
for long enough if they believed in
their ability to play together they
could win anything
they were almost right Oh Jean one for
dota 2 majors more than any other team
in history and every time the
International came around they were
favourites prediction one whele og with
fly at the helm as captain and no tail
at his side oh gee looks strong going
into TI they boasted team chemistry one
of the best players in dota history and
promising rookies but they never
succeeded things shifted ahead of TI 8
the og of the 2017-2018 season was not
the og fans came to recognize the team
just couldn't put together wins when it
mattered falling to weaker teams and
lagging behind in the dota 2 pro circuit
it looked like they weren't going to
make it to TI in may fly broke the
promise on which og was founded after
two years of leading building in
supporting og he left he took Gustav s
for Magnussen and went to evil geniuses
long considered North America's best
team Evil Geniuses has never had the
player loyalty that defined og that
isn't necessarily a bad thing as the
team is a perennial TI powerhouse
but it means that even after winning TI
they were willing to drop one of the
players that earned them the aegis
we ended up releasing a UI and bringing
in our old teammate rtz
to play with us and it's just kind of
what we every one on our team thought
was best for us going into this next
year they've got the money the
reputation and the core talent that
could convince any player to leave one
team and join their hallowed ranks and
fly was convinced by an s4 why did you
leave oh gee the team hasn't worked for
a long time and I can say personally
that I lost a lot of motivation when the
whole situation arises where I could
join eg I felt a new surge of motivation
where I felt like this is really a team
I could win with as opposed to the
previous scene where I felt like we kind
of hit a dead end in the end I want to
win and I want to do it with teammates I
believe in the change meant that both EG
and og would have to go through the open
qualifiers to make Ti but the addition
of fly and s4 made eg suddenly look like
serious contenders to lift the aegis of
champions at least on paper oh gee on
the other hand were disregarded without
their captain and one of their star
players fans didn't even think they
could make it through the open
qualifiers og signed tobias tops and
tuffets sane and a promising young
rookie and moved their coach
Sebastian Seb debs onto the main line up
still few had og pegged to make a deep
run at TI or even make it at all but if
there's anything that can fuel a team to
victory it's revenge gg gg is the call
her G will be the European
representative for the qualifiers going
to the International 2018 but even once
they made it to TI hopes weren't high
for OG they saw a lot of questions
around urging yes Micah's like you look
at L GD l GD attacked up in the top
three to go through but og were a team
that came through like they obviously
had the roster ripped apart by evil
genius
but they were at ti and that meant they
had a chance a chance to win but perhaps
more importantly a chance to get revenge
on their former captain their brother
who betrayed them
it is obviously never gonna be easy to
win a TI nobody has done it twice but
this year I think our chances are
actually better than they've ever been
that's my personal gut feeling Oh G had
a tough group
arguably the harder of the two but they
stayed strong even after taking a 2o
loss to fly an eg on the second day
except the Mehran and they're gonna GG
at eg have turned around a bad start
here in gate number 2 and taken down Oh
G and in the end they came out and
fourth with a spot in the upper bracket
and a clear path to a faded rematch
against eg both eg and og dispatched
their first-round opponent reviews
okay moving on
[Music]
[Music]
they might be in trouble
all of eg James don't fall they were
qualified for the upper bracket
semi-finals for a match against each
other the stage was set
eg against og blue against green brother
against brother fly against no tail so
we're gonna talk about the thing that
everybody is talking about which is s4
and fly leaving and you all had to reset
pretty quickly no it's all for you how
what was that like going through that
change unless you know that willing to
talk about it yeah it's something for
later yeah there then can you help
people understand why you don't want to
talk about it so that there you can only
be along just personal everyone has
their own analogy about this matchup
right there's there's many stories to be
told but obviously one that dates a
little back to the old og squad and how
now these two squads have come to be in
their current form winner day do you
think that's gonna play a role of this
matchup between the two yeah
both teams understand each other
talk about seeing what do you want to do
it he's got his eyes on the pic any time
to pack the gate the tornador coming to
the sides
Derek's on TV still that with the shadow
blade set trying to get taken out by
some at the Savannah place but in the
iSchool Jackson goes down to us another
fighter for the code snapchats you check
that the magnetized rubbish I'm still
alive for now the silent streets it out
onto trucks in August
game-worn was close
and if series what I think a lot of
people have expected to see something
quite when classic from eg energy they
have somebody drops you 32 minutes in 80
and while Game two looked close as well
just on the mid lane eg that tried to
fight but cement he's going up but then
she go down as well the car started
sticking out he's got the stick
challenges but again you slow the rain
put down sysml child get out black Audi
christophe's backups the high ground
curse from no toe comes out of the curry
and Thompson seeping out of it all hang
on then take him into these noble eg
still managed to snuff them out in a
dominant performance
[Applause]
the score was 1:1 eg were still the
favorite and OG still the underdogs
sitting directly across from fly no tail
knew exactly how much was on the line
he wasn't just fighting for a spot in
the upper bracket finals he wasn't just
fighting for more prize money he was
fighting for his principles for his
belief in a team he and fly built on an
understanding that loyalty and
friendship meant more than money for
championships no tail was fighting for
the very soul of og and his team was
behind him every step of the way things
gone off to a bad start for og
can I get spokes in out of here they cat
off and they only got worse
eg had taken to Roshan's had the
pressure on oh jeez barracks and we're
getting ready to close out the game but
og persevered and pulled out a miracle
yes we saw eg in game to make quite a
comeback kid og may even come back here
in game 3
after a grueling at 53 minute game hoji
emerged victorious and no tail had his
revenge
even Jesus is knocking at you down to
the rock
gee whiz let's get closer to the other
jefes believe in the comebacks we had
between these two teams into
back-to-back games og with the fortitude
to skip through it and eat the evening
with such a bowl
no itself I mean you can feel it this
game there was the drama there was the
passion and oh gee
against any of the team
the time for revenge was over now it was
time for vindication it's the element of
surprise that they have to play on so
I'm expecting just a lot of creativity
from them but if LGD show up with their
absolute best eye I do feel like they
have an edge
yeah a lot of times it did feel like og
was kind of able to force mistakes out
of their opponent by surprise and then
take advantage of that momentum whereas
LGD we've discussed earlier just plays a
clean game despite beating eg og had a
long way to go there was still one more
team between them and the grand finals
PSG LGD up until 2018 TI was defined by
a cycle every even year a Chinese team
lifted the aegis an LGD were the only
Chinese team left in the bracket of
course it wasn't just fate that was on
their side it was skill LGD may have
only come out of the group stage in
third place but they dominated two
powerhouse teams on their way to the
upper bracket finals 200 per both virtus
Pro and defending champions team
we'll take liquid through a bracket and
move on but by now OG were used to being
the underdogs this was already their
best Ti performance in the teams history
why not just take it a little far he's
got the control
he's got the kill Thompson is done but
he ends up where the actors sign father
[Applause]
once again oh geez silence their
doubters they defeated LGD 2-1 thanks to
an incredible comeback and secured a
spot in the grand finals
Oh G was one match away from the ages
one match away from the victory that had
escaped them for so long one match away
from proving that they didn't need fly
or s for they just needed to believe in
the thing that had gotten og so far in
the first place the belief that working
together as a team and trusting each
other would get them the rest of the way
LGD dispatched eg 200 in the lower
bracket finals to earn another shot at
øg øg took the first game
[Applause]
G taking Game one of this best-of-five
in the 2018 international Grand Finals
but LGD rallied taking to one sided
games back to back
[Applause]
oh gee had their backs to the wall is it
for the side he's got a double down to
treat as well that flies there in
underneath the tower punching down
Thompson Thompson bulls once again Jones
comes into the tether of course they try
to find something to response but
Jarrett he's in trouble you arrive they
get the kill and fly some og able to
strike back in that mid lane with the
rotation getting that we got manova
walks in against the easiest with so
much on the line with so little room for
error no one expected former coach said
to save OG but
all of his lifetime
oh gee Dino and it kept them alive for
one last game oh gee went in with a
lineup of some of the least picked
heroes at the tournament and LGD took
advantage of that as soon as the game
started why there is for the set up the
Bishop into the combo Tom will be dodged
no tells how's she gonna TP him for this
one a sunless beats down on to Jared's
Jarek seven to get himself away no he's
done once again LGD took an early lead
but og has been here before
the whole tournament was one big
comeback so what better way to close it
out and with
[Music]
just still alive throughout the soul
never lost Thompson the slightly changed
the record across town get the killer to
charities in the minimal use it himself
of the flame God ticking it for another
the son of theirs
as our G they fight three they look
towards of the surrounding in the pit
summers he'll go down as well securing
the by m4g as only a server left alive
but not for long they chased him down
the ancient is exposed as og the newest
away from Sam gets themselves another on
to the agent
[Applause]
friendship
you're glad champions
gee oh gee emerged victorious after a
close 3-2 series after a tournament
filled with comebacks and close calls
after getting revenge on evil geniuses
fake Charlie they 2 3 4 News team
Thompson he's only been for a couple of
days he's only 43,000 before this oh my
goodness oh gee congratulations
gee oh gee does
[Applause]
they didn't follow anyone else strategy
maybe that was they just played their
own game and
but perhaps most importantly they
emerged victorious after proving
themselves
at the International 2018 no-tail
Gerak's said anna and thompson proved
that the fundamental belief that created
OG was true
sometimes sticking together working hard
and believing in the team you've built
means more than just the best all-star
roster that money can buy even when your
friends lose their way and become your
enemy even when the world is against you
as a favorite for a signal series they
played at TI you persevere because the
trust you've created can begin and
[Applause]
I guess it's real
breathe and take your time
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button